Armenia has adopted the statute of the
international criminal court the IC that
means it would have to observe an arrest
warrant for Russian President Vladimir
Putin on suspicion of war crimes
armenia's Parliament ratified the Rome
statute on Tuesday that brings the
country under the jurisdiction of the
ICC in the ha the plan had been strongly
opposed by Russia armenia's formal Ally
but ties have become strained since
aaban took control of the car back
region Julia Shava is standing by for us
in Moscow first let's go to Bernard
Smith who's live in yavan you are where
this is all happening Bernard this is no
coincidence connect the dots for us of
what's been happening in carabat and
this move by The Armenian
government seral The Armenian government
will say uh that there isn't a major
Connection in in fact signed the
government signed the Rome statute back
in 1998 more than 20 years ago but has
only just now passed it into law it's an
indication on one side of Russia's
waning influence here not just on on
Armenia but also over aaban waning
influence because Armenia considers the
Russia in the end didn't come to its
defense and help protect the ethnic
Armenians in carabat and Armenia now
more interested in making alliances with
Europe and the United States but the
government also says that even though
it's ratified this this state this
treaty it will not arrest Vladimir Putin
should he come here the government says
here it considers Vladimir Putin a head
of state and their interpretation of the
law is that he wouldn't be arrested
nevertheless as we know the Russians are
not happy about it Armenia says this is
more about aaban and by signing up to
the IC it allows Armenia to bring cases
against the a against aaban Armenia is
interested in bringing cases over the
2020 War for example and before it can
do that it needs to ratify uh the Rome
State
Statute okay if I can get you to Pivot
fully now to what is happening in the
carabat region where almost all ethnic
Armenians have fled what do you know and
we've been trying to find out more about
this over the last few days what do you
know about Armenians who have stayed in
carab
back we know that there aren't many of
them who have stayed in carabat anything
between from one un team anything from
between 50 to a thousand ethnic
Armenians are there we know that some
members of the leadership of the
administration of nagoro carab back when
it was administered by ethnic Armenians
they are still there and we know that as
aijan says it's been holding talks with
these people we don't know whether they
face arrest or whether they'll be
allowed to leave freely but the ey of
the Red Cross has also been there and
the and they all describe it as a as a
ghost town a ghost region because
everybody has left everyone 100,000 just
over 100,000 to here Armenia is giving
them cash grants for 6 months urging to
open bank accounts to take those cash
grants and international agencies have
been on hand giving out blankets and
food for those who who for those who are
here Bernard Smith reporting from yavan
thank you very much let me turn to Julia
shavala in Moscow so Russia will look or
is looking at this um the the uh
adoption of the Rome statutes and uh
signing um or accepting the authority of
the ICC I should say as an extremely
hostile move walk us through moscow's
position
here well absolutely and we're getting
some first negative reactions from
Russian officials right now so
officially Russia is not happy at all to
say the least about armenia's
ratification of the Rome statute of the
international criminal court uh we've
heard several times also from the
Russian foreign Ministry that it's
unacceptable it will have negative
consequences for bilateral relations uh
Moscow explained that uh in the current
conditions when the IC had issued arrest
warrants for the top leadership of
Russia The Armenian Partners were asked
to ref refrain from making that decision
but apart from the fact the ratification
would mean that Armenia had to arrest
Vladimir Putin if he appeared on on its
soil and hand him over to the
international criminal court which
issued a warrant for Putin's arrest in
back in March so apart from that earlier
in September when prime minister
pashinyan explained the decision to join
uh because in his opinion the collective
security Treaty Organization and the
Armenian Russian relationship uh were
insufficient to ensure the country's
security something that Moscow was not
pleased to hear at all so armenia's
intention was considered unfriendly and
on September the 8th The Armenian
Ambassador was summoned to the foreign
ministry as well look Armenia and Russia
are formal allies do you see this
causing a real breakup between the
two well uh technically the breakup
between the two
countries is hardly possible even though
currently the relations have soured due
to the caraba conflict and there may be
some serious political differences and
accusations from both sides but the
country is old um their their centuries
old ties economic relationship support
and friendship can't be completely
destroyed you know yavan ins says the
decision is not aimed at Moscow
according to Armenia as it was mentioned
it intends to use the international
criminal court to hold aaban accountable
for what it calls war crimes and attacks
against Armenia and its people and uh it
it it is an argument why wouldn't we
trust it after all Vladimir Putin is not
forever and one day he will go believe
it or not but Rome statute is there to
stay at least for a while Julia shavala
reporting from Moscow thank you very
much